son rivales políticos y algunos expertos
los han llegado a catalogar de Némesis
lucinacio Lula da Silva de origen
humilde se convirtió en obrero
metalúrgico y sindicalista en Sao Paulo
mientras que bolsonaron hacían El Dorado
rodeado de áreas de preservación
indígena donde comenzó a idolatrar al
ejército y el uso de las armas Sin armas
del gobierno quiere que esas personas de
bien no tengan Paz en la calle y tampoco
en sus casas Lula emergió en el mundo de
la política como líder sindical junto al
partido de los trabajadores desde su
fundación defendiendo la justicia social
y el bienestar de los más pobres se va a
enriquecer a los ricos y empobrecer a
los pobres aún más tras su carrera
militar bolsonaro saltó a la política
como diputado federal pero siguió
defendiendo los valores militares con
muchos represores de la dictadura
militar como ídolos por el ejército de
las cajas por nuestras fuerzas armadas
por Brasil por encima de todo y por Dios
por encima de todos
en lo ambiental bolsonaro dinami la
concesión de reservas indígenas y amplió
los permisos para explotar la amazonía
ya tenemos más del 14% de nuestro
territorio nacional de marcado como
tierras indígenas
pretendían que mi gobierno llegará al
20%, eso invalidaría nuestra economía
en cambio de Luna ha ido acercándose a
temas como el ambiental o los derechos
de los indígenas con el paso del tiempo
que han tenido un fuerte peso en la
campaña de este 2022
respetaremos la amazonía nuestro bosque
sin embargo hay zonas grises en las que
los dos candidatos no son tan diferentes
en especial respecto a la religión en el
centro de la campaña en el país laico
algo que ha empujado a Lula regular en
posturas progresistas llegando a decir
que estaba personalmente contra el
aborto la vida es el mayor Don que nos
ha dado Dios
y bolsonaro ha mantenido su discurso en
contra del aborto de la ideología de
género y a favor de la familia
tradicional una elección entre la l de
Lula o la l a favor de las armas del
bolsonarismo